in diesen tagen ist die
millionenmetropole am schwarzen meer in
den schlagzeilen es heißt putin wolle
die strategisch wichtige hafenstadt
einnehmen die nähe zu russland auch in
der bevölkerung spürbar fast jeder
dritte hier ist rote stämmig und die
mehrheit spricht russisch zu hause wir
wollen wissen wie gehen die menschen
hier um mit der sich zuspitzenden
bedrohung an der grenze
zu gast bei einem bei dem die stadt ein
und ausgeht
[Musik]
mein ganzes interesse im leben spiegelt
sich komplett in meinem geschäft zu 100
prozent
libyen ist einer der einflussreichsten
kirche der ukraine hier den odessa hat
er vier restaurants zwei neue entstehen
grad
seine mission die liebe die er für seine
heimatstadt empfindet auf den teller
bringen und die ganze welt davon kosten
lassen wo würfelglück seine gäste kommen
überwiegend aus der stadt es seien ganz
normale bürger sagt sawa schließlich
seien seine preise erschwinglich und
auch für den durchschnitt ukraine gilt
das nicht die ukraine ist das ärmste
land in europa das durchschnittliche
monatseinkommen liegt bei umgerechnet
350 euro wo sieht sich selber lebt in
der man mit den sechs restaurants in
dieser gesellschaft
ich und alle um mich herum
all die geschäftsmänner in odessa
gehören zur mittelschicht
auch wenn sie möglicherweise denken sie
seien etwas besseres
nein das sind sie nicht sie gehören
allenfalls zur mittelschicht
ob er angst habe dass die drohende
militärische eskalation mit russland
auswirkungen haben könne auf sein
geschäft wollen wir noch wissen
ich spreche nicht über politik
keine politik
zu heikel findet er gerade jetzt in
diesem aufgeladenen konflikt schließlich
biss aber keine kunden verprellen der
krieg in der ost ukraine scheint für ihn
weit weg nur wenige straßenzüge von
service restaurant entfernt mitten in
der innenstadt ein besetztes haus hier
hat sich slavomir einquartiert für ihn
ist der krieg nach der rentner hat am
eigenen leibe erfahren was es bedeutet
wenn russland land gewinnen will
ich komme aus der dann jetzt region aus
der stadt dir sind jetzt heißt die
stadttore sie wurde umbenannt
[Musik]
unsere stadt liegt an der front deshalb
musste ich weg
seine stadt war vom prorussischen
separatisten besetzt der damals
53-jährige war in dieser zeit panzer
abwehr kommandant und bekämpfte an der
front seiner ehemaligen pro russischen
nachbarn vor fünf jahren dann die flucht
nur erwünscht seien er und die anderen
donners flüchtlinge nicht strom und
wasser hat die stadt odessa vor jahren
abgestellt die flüchtlinge stören
[Musik]
die stadtverwaltung sagt uns nicht warum
sie das tun aber wir all die bewohner
des hauses sind uns sicher dass sie uns
auf die straße schmeißen wollen
hauptsache raus aus dem haus ist auch
logisch das gebäude liegt sehr gut
direkt im stadtzentrum
ich glaube irgendwer will das gebäude
haben
doch slawomir denkt gar nicht daran
seine neue heimat zu verlassen nur weil
er nicht ins selbstbild von odessa passt
die mondäne stadt lebt vom tourismus und
von ihrem image prunkbauten
luxusboutiquen dolce vita
[Musik]
diana mironenko verdient genau damit ihr
geld die 27-jährige ist miss earth aus
odessa
[Musik]
wir sind ein bisschen verrückt was die
schönheit angeht das kommt von unserer
vergangenheit wir wollten immer schön
sein und die kleidung tragen die wir
nicht kannten
diana wünscht sich eine moderne ukraine
die sich am besten orientiert
gleichzeitig habe sie wie viele hier
familie in russland eine identität
geprägt von zwei nationen auf
konfrontationskurs
wir haben keinen hass natürlich werden
wir unser land verteidigen wenn etwas
passieren sollte aber wir lassen
niemanden
zurück im besetzten haus ein stockwerk
tiefer
olga ist von der arbeit zurück sie ist
krankenschwester auf der intensivstation
im hiesigen krankenhaus danach
hausaufgabenbetreuung für den kleinen
sohn im halbdunkeln wut und hass
verspüre auch sie nicht aber nur weil
sie seit ihrer flucht aus dem
kriegsgebiet keine zeit mehr habe
hier wurden gewarnt dass wir die
nächsten sein könnten und dass es besser
wäre zu fliehen
erst konnte mir das gar nicht glauben
aber dann hörten wir die explosion die
tasten schnell unsere sachen und haben
die stadt verlassen
ich und mein ältester sohn er war damals
in der ersten schulklasse es war august
2014 als wir gingen
ihr sohn hat seitdem ein trauma muss zur
therapie olga ist alleinerziehend lebt
auf zwölf quadratmetern mit ihrer mutter
und den beiden söhnen und obwohl jahre
vergangen sind kommt die familie einfach
nicht zur ruhe
das schlimmste ist die kälte wir werden
an dauernd krank die kinder waren diesen
winter schon dreimal krank ich auch und
auch meine mutter aber wir können uns
kein anderes appartement leisten die
bank gibt uns keinen kredit wegen der
hohen zinsen und ich bin allein
verdienerin ich kann mir das nicht
leisten es ist kein neid den sie
verspürt wenn sie ihre wohlhabenden
nachbarn in der noblen innenstadt von
odessa sieg nur der wunsch nach einer
neuen heimat und die angst davor das
trauma des krieges noch einmal
durchleben zu müssen
[Musik]